what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 got a big
group right here the group behind how to
blow up a pipeline my God this movie a
lot happens in a very short period of
time I emphasize how big this Ensemble
was because not only do you have to
convey the information necessary to pull
off this plan but you also give just
enough backstory on every single
character to convey the purpose of why
they are doing this I was very impressed
I feel like I don't need to ask you to
do this after I just blabbed about it
but can you give everyone out there who
does not know what this movie is a brief
synopsis of it yeah the the movie is
based on uh Manifesto by uh climate
activist named Andreas malm uh who
basically writes about the fact that
every single social justice movement in
history has at the very least been
predicated on the destruction of
property and that climate change poses
an existential threat to human life on
Earth and is kind of questioning whether
or not property destruction is necessary
to move away from fossil fuels and
preserve human civilization in society
as we know it and so we adapted these
ideas
um you know the book has no story it's
just kind of political Theory we adapted
these ideas uh into essentially a heist
Thriller film about eight young people
young climate activists who uh blow up
an oil pipeline in rural Texas and
um the movie kind of walks you through
in pretty exacting detail how they build
the bombs and how they do it and uh in
kind of classic Heist fashion they have
a a very complex and exciting Plan
before we get into all the details and
the character specifics I am really
curious how do you go from cam to this
because cam was so good so I imagine you
have someone in your corner saying like
just stick with horror and this feels so
different I mean definitely after Cam
most of the industry opportunity that
was like available to me was in horror
but I think that you know me and all the
people that I work with you know Isa
mudsey who produced this movie and wrote
and produced Cam Jordan Shoal who wrote
and produced this movie and was a writer
on cam like you know we all kind of our
idea first filmmakers and for me like I
love all genre kind of equally and I
think for me it's about how do I take a
really great idea and make a film out of
it that's exciting that can you know
really connect with a wide audience uh
but that also really has like something
meaningful to say and so for me this is
like honestly like a completely natural
extension from cam
um you know in a lot of ways and it's a
lot of the same people and I've also
been lucky enough to add a bunch of new
people to the collaborative team and
collaborative efforts so I like seeing
you show off your range I love all types
of movies horror is my number one so
when you return to the genre I will be
there as well I want to be able to
highlight everyone's character here so a
big group question jump in whenever you
feel ready but just to highlight how
they influence the plan and who they
kind of are as a person what would you
say is their greatest asset in pulling
all of this off but then also what's
their greatest weakness that over the
course of the film could completely
obliterate their chances of making this
work
wow I feel like it's a good tease
without spoilers Maybe
yeah I I think for for Sean one of his
greatest strengths was his his people
skills
um he was able to
come to so many different people from
different backgrounds and recruit them
under the same like-minded goal
um and his biggest weakness definitely
is his fear
um I think he came from a background
where he wasn't directly impacted by
these refineries so while committed to
the plan and definitely wanting to take
a stance and make a change he also was
afraid for his future obviously he wants
to continue going to college and having
a great normal life
um so I think his fear kind of ruined a
lot of the things in the in the film
for Alicia her greatest asset was her
skepticism kept everybody in check uh
just about what what is actually
possible and and and keeping us grounded
on why we're doing what we're doing and
then our greatest weakness has to be uh
Theo who Sasha Lane can be here but um I
think the whole her whole reason for
being there it totally and solely
depends on on Theo so
I think Logan's
biggest strength is his fearlessness
and it's also his weakness because he's
an impulsive
um sometimes thoughtless guy
I'll say Michael's greatest strength is
probably that he could do this by
himself but that's awesome
that's also yeah
yeah Michael carries Michael carries
I feel like that's his greatest weakness
as well because it just would have you
know blown up in his face probably
yeah I think sochi's biggest strength is
probably her passion and her
intelligence to you know put a plan like
this together and her greatest weakness
is her all-consuming ego
um that you know someone also simply has
to have to put themselves at the center
of a plan like this
um so I played Dwayne's wife so I'll
just speak a little bit to Dwayne it's
like basically I think his greatest
strength is his courage
um and his determination logically hit
the way that he knows the land is
obviously a big strength but I think he
has the Texas grit that when someone
hurts themselves he's like all right
strap in like let's handle this
um and I'd say his weakness is not a
personal weakness but probably the fact
that his family lives in poverty and the
risk that he's taking doing this has
pretty extreme repercussions I'll go
back around here and I'll stay with you
you also mentioned that you are a script
consultant here what exactly does that
mean and how did you contribute to what
we see in the final film so I was the
Texan script consultant because I was
born and raised there uh particularly in
an oil rig town called Baytown so I had
a similar upbringing to Sasha Lane's
character where I was exposed to acid
rain and and a lot of pollution my
entire family lineage is manual labor
workers at these oil rig companies that
are you know wildly underpaid and so
Danny and Ariella came to me and were
like hey we have a Texan storyline in
this and we know that you have personal
stories attached not just to Texas but
to the oil industry and it was great to
kind of be along the ride for the script
and shape Dwayne in a way that felt
really authentic and not just a
caricature of a Texan so Ariella did you
two know each other before making this
how did you two come together for for
the writing process we met
um briefly right before uh shutdown
because Danny was making another movie
and I I ended up we met for it and then
he cast me and then that was the
Thursday before lockdown and then
everything fell apart
guess what I cast around on the leave of
this movie and then and then like a week
later that it was like no more movie uh
and and but yeah I I just thought you
know she was so brilliant and
intelligent and we really wanted to work
together and so uh you know we were just
kind of looking for something and
talking a lot during the pandemic and
then this project kind of just very
naturally came together wait I'm sorry
this project was going to go before the
pandemic like a whole different movie
that no longer exists okay okay R.I.P
might not no longer exist you never know
what could happen no it doesn't exist
in that case it doesn't exist
um how about for you
executive producer how did that part uh
come into your role um I feel like it
was just starting with early
conversations about the movie in like
early stages when I believe it was just
Sasha Lane and I were like attached to
the project the script was going under a
lot of revisions especially with like
the Michael character side of it and um
it was like my just instruction which is
like not typically with like just this
film but like every film like there's
usually never a native or indigenous
perspective anywhere so like usually
that burden is set on me and I feel like
this was the first film where like Danny
just opened up the web to like a series
of like consultants and people who we
like either interviewed with us like
through the tiniest specifics like seed
conservation or like people who live the
life of like a son of like a
revolutionary or just all these people
and then I came in just from a character
perspective and so like in the end of
this amalgamation of us just working
together we ended up shooting in January
on my reservation in North Dakota in
negative 40 degree weather for two days
with a crew that was like all from La so
it was like
so like you know like that sort of
consultation turns into a very horrible
experience
you're explaining that yeah exactly we
were shooting on film and the camera
literally would freeze and the film
would not move so we had to strap like
hot hands to the camera just to like be
able to shoot we'd have to shoot in like
15 20 minute bursts before we would have
to like take the camera back into the
van just to like warm it up just so it
could like shoot again uh uh but yeah
that that that that entire experience
was forest's vision for the North Dakota
leg of the movie that that was really
something that he had a
the the shot with him in the flame Spire
he you know the first time we met he was
like we're gonna we're gonna go get this
this this stuff and dragged us all out
there I have to rap with you guys soon I
have so many more questions
um oh my God Lucas I'll go to you first
um Logan and Rowan just kept me on my
toes from start to finish we're like I
did understand who they were but I also
never knew what they were capable of
what is it like trying to keep the
audience on their toes like that but
also making sure there was some
consistency in the characters and their
decisions that's a really good question
I I liked that they were enigmas and a
bit mysterious and kind of the
they had a separate storyline that I
feel like the rest of the group they
were kind of doing their own thing in
the shadows but I think
it's a big Testament to Danny and
Ariella to keep me
keep me going and um the characters Arc
and the development and knowing where it
was going because I had to kind of keep
reminding myself and Trust because
you know the movie
it jumps time jumps a lot and I I I
needed a lot of help
um so but it was fun though it made
playing him so fun and it was a lot of
just going with my impulses and and
having a free
free performance but being connected
with the one yeah how much of your
performance do you think is improv I
would say 40 40 I'd say I'd say like
there's like a lot
yeah
because I learned this just the other
day Lucas like his first day on set
walked up to the the script supervisor
and was like just so you know I'm gonna
be uh rewriting some lines so keep an
eye out and uh I mean like it's he's an
amazing improviser like it really like
like they're like so many jokes so many
like incredible just like moments thank
you yeah mother's milk yeah man I'm a
script supervisor's worst nightmare
oh they're making me rap with you too so
I I just will say at least your
Chemistry with Sasha Lane is just pitch
perfect and the leadership dynamic in
this movie and how you guys convey that
your characters are the leaders but also
making everyone feel equal as part of
this plan is just something that really
stood out to me I wish I could talk to
you all day about your movie I have to
let you go huge huge huge
congratulations to you and thank you for
coming by today thank you so much to
everybody out there stay tuned more Tiff
2020 two interviews at the supper Suite
soon